ungewollt schwanger trotz Verhütung das
Kind will sie nicht behalten sie ziehe
gerade erst mit ihrem Freund zusammen ja
man überlegt ja schon auf die richtige
Entscheidung war aber
man hat sich entschieden
die Patientin möchte anonym bleiben
ihren Schwangerschaftsabbruch dürfen wir
zeigen erst Vollnarkose dann Absaugung
Konstanze Haare operiert an diesem Tag
in Berlin 12 ungewollt Schwangere
12 Entscheidungen gegen das Kind
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche gehören zu den
häufigsten gynäkologischen Eingriffen in
Deutschland doch immer weniger Ärzte
wollen Abtreibungen durchführen seit
2003 hat sich die Zahl fast halbiert
sucht man konkret nach einem Arzt dann
für die Liste der Bundesärztekammer noch
365 Adressen bundesweit in manchen
Regionen Deutschlands gibt es keinen
einzigen Arzt mehr der
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche durchführt
für ganz Deutschland gesprochen ist die
Versorgungslage nicht gut und wird auch
schlechter über die letzten Jahre wir
erleben und hören auch immer Geschichten
dass gerade im ländlichen Gebieten und
auch in anderen Bundesländern die
versorgen sehr viel schlechter ist
fehlende Ausbildung Belästigung durch
Abtreibungsgegner vor allem sei der
Paragraph 218 Strafgesetzbuch ein Gesetz
von
1871 der Abbruch eines Straftat geregelt
hinter Mord und Totschlag er bleibt nur
straffrei bis zur 12 Woche nach
Pflichtberatung und Wartezeit auf einen
Arzttermin
ja man muss ja relativ viel machen wenn
man sich dazu entscheidet abzutreiben es
ist ja relativ bürokratisch dass sie
eine Straftat immer noch darstellt
irgendwie
das ist ein bisschen mühsamen Arzt
aufsuchen dann Beratungsstelle ganzen
Termine vereinbaren nicht mehr oder
weniger rechtfertigen wer in Berlin oder
Hamburg wohnt hat derzeit kein Problem
dort auch einen Arzt für einen
Schwangerschaftsabbruch zu finden das
sieht im katholischen Bayern schon
anders aus Beispiel auch Augsburg in der
Uniklinik gibt es keine Ärzte die
ungewollte Schwangerschaften ohne
Indikation beenden Augsburgerinnen
müssen in die Umgebung oder bis nach
München fahren ausgerechnet hier
demonstrieren sie jeden Sonntag gegen
Abtreibung guten Tag ab wann haben
Menschenrechte
was meinen Sie was ist das wir sind ein
Verein wir versuchen mit Leuten über
abtreibungsgespräch zu kommen
ein Mann drüber nachdenken ist wichtig
ist eine wichtige Frage es geht um
Abtreibung wir möchten mit Menschen
überhaupt ins Gespräch kommen
was macht ihr nichts das ist auch
wichtig dass mit anderen Menschen drüber
redet die Lebensschützer von Sundays for
Life sehen sich als notwendige
Gegenbewegung zur
Bundesfamilienministerin die will
Paragraph 218 streichen und
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche neu regeln wenn
man sagt dass auch ein ungeborener
Mensch ein Fötus ein menschlicher Fötus
ein ja der biologisch ein Mensch ist und
lebt das ist auch der Rechte hat man
kann es keinen wirklichen Moment geben
an dem Abtreibung okay ist und das das
Denken auch wir ich glaube das
Abtreibung
ein furchtbares furchtbares Verbrechen
ist das verharmlost wird
warum wird verharmlos weil die Menschen
sich das Recht rausnehmen ein
egoistisches Leben zu leben nur weil der
Körper von diesen Baby in meinem Körper
ist gibt mir das noch nicht das Recht
über das Leben oder über den Tod von dem
Kind in meinem Bauch zu entscheiden es
ist nicht für mich nicht mein Körper und
für mich gibt es keinen Grund für eine
Abtreibung deutschland brauche die
abschreckende Wirkung von Paragraph 218
ohne den Straftatbestand gebe es nicht
nur viel mehr Abtreibungen
das würde im Endeffekt bedeuten
Abtreibung bis zur Geburt zu
legalisieren wenn man keine keine
weiteren Regelungen einführt die
Abtreibung irgendwie anschränken keine
Fristenlösung
und dann wäre es ohne Grund möglich ja
ein wirklich im 9 Monat ein Kind noch
abzutreiben aber wer tut das die Zahl
der Schwangerschaftsabbrüche hat sich in
den letzten Jahren deutlich reduziert
erst 2022 mit Inflation und Ukraine
Krieg erstmals wieder erhöht
ihr Abbruch ist jetzt einen Tag her wir
nennen Sie Nadine die 29-Jährige und ihr
Mann haben bereits zwei Kinder ein
drittes diese umziehen in München er
Mietvertrag steht ausdrücklich Wohnung
für 4 dazu ist sie mitten in der
Ausbildung
das habe ich mich auch gefragt was ist
wenn ich jetzt doch das dritte Kind
bekommen und es geht nicht also wir sind
zwar beide Vollzeit arbeiten aber
ansonsten können sie sich nein also vor
allen Dingen hier nicht und man hat halt
dann auch Schuldgefühle
und es ist so schwierig also und man
weiß nicht so in drei Tagen muss ich
mich entschieden haben heute ist es so
morgen ist es so dann ist es am anderen
Tag wieder so ach so zwischen den
beratungster
furchtbar wirklich also ich fand es ganz
schlimm und es war die schwierigste
Entscheidung
wir haben die Deutschen gefragt könnte
man § 218 Strafgesetzbuch streichen die
Mehrheit ist dagegen
54% sagen der Straftatbestand soll er
weiterhin gelten 36% wollen den
abschaffen
bei jungen Menschen fällt das Ergebnis
umgekehrt aus vor allem junge Frauen
unter 35 Jahren die in gebärfähigen
Alter wollen nur zu 44% Paragraph 218
erhalten 50% wollen ihn abschaffen
dieser Generation Konflikt wird in
Passau bereits deutlich in Sachen
Selbstbestimmung liegen Sie hier gleich
mehrere Schritte zurück nur eine einzige
Ärztin führt Abbrüche durch eine in ganz
Niederbayern im Film will sie lieber
nicht auftauchen Ihre Telefonnummer
erhält man wenn man in der Klinik nach
Abtreibung fragt
Studierende der Uni Passau wollten das
ändern und Schwangerschaftsabbrüche am
Städtischen Klinikum durchsetzen fast
7000 Unterschriften haben sie der Stadt
übergeben in Passau aber blieb trotzdem
alles beim Alten
ich denke viele haben tatsächlich den
Eindruck es ist ja okay es gibt ja eine
Lösung und machen sich gar nicht bewusst
wie viele Probleme es eigentlich noch
gibt
das ist eben nicht reicht dass es
straffrei ist sondern dass es dann eben
auch jemand geben muss der diese
Möglichkeit anbietet es nützt mir nichts
nicht dafür bestraft zu werden zu
treiben wenn ich niemanden finde der
diese Abtreibung durchführt mich
persönlich stört dass ich glaube das ist
ein Menschenrecht ist oder seinen
eigenen Körper zu entscheiden und dass
die Tatsache dass
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche kriminalisiert
sind und so schwierig überhaupt
durchzuführen sind das ist so schwierig
ist eine Ärztin zu finden ist für mich
einfach eine Grundrechtsverletzung ohne
Angebote keine Abbrüche die bayerische
Art ganze Regionen abtreibungsfrei zu
halten
frontal fragt beim Obi von Passau nach
der schreibt ein Beschuss des Stadtrates
von 2007 habe für das Klinikum die
Durchführung von
Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen nach der
Fristenregelung abgelehnt
selbstverständlicher wenn man großes
Verständnis für die schwierige Situation
der Frauen nur behandeln lassen sollen
sie sich möglichst irgendwo anders und
das gilt nicht nur für Niederbayern
ich bin Lehrerin Bayern es darf niemand
erfahren dass ich abgetrieben habe in
Augsburg konnte man mir keinen Arzt
empfehlen ich bin dann in eine Klinik
bis nach München gefahren ständig hat
man das Gefühl etwas sehr schlimmes und
Verbotenes zu tun die 700 € für die OP
habe ich bar bezahlt damit nichts auf
dem Kontoauszug zu sehen ist und auch
die Krankschreibung habe ich von einem
anderen Arzt umschreiben lassen bei
Klinik statt wissen ja sonst alles
sofort Bescheid
Friedrich Stapf führt rund ein Viertel
aller Abbrüche in Bayern durch
2.500 pro Jahr bis zu 200 Kilometer weit
fahren seine Patientinnen Stab der Arzt
der im Hawaiihemd operiert ist 77 und
könnte längst im Ruhestand sein haben
Sie gedacht dass sie doch mit 77 im OP
stehen würden also ich wollte eigentlich
mal mit 80 dann aufhören vielleicht
es gibt keine Nachfolger
wenn viele mit Paragraph 218 die
Strafbarkeit würde das keinen
abtreibungsboom auslösen aber auch nicht
automatisch für mehr Ärzte sorgen
bevor sie da in diesen Städten jemand
kriegen der Abbrüche macht muss das
die Gesellschaft sich ändern und das
ob wir das heutzutage noch hinkriegen
weiß ich nicht zurück in der Berliner
Klinik Deutschland schützt ungeborenes
Leben immer noch mit strafrechtlichen
Mitteln
ein Schwangerschaftsabbruch sollte eine
Gesundheitsleistung sein und nicht ein
komplizierter Prozess der in einem
Strafgesetzbuch geregelt ist also das
gehört einfach nicht ins Strafgesetzbuch
vor 30 Jahren legten Richter des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts Fest eine Frau
ist in Deutschland grundsätzlich dazu
verpflichtet eine Schwangerschaft
auszutragen ihr Urteil bestimmt heute
noch das Leben von jungen Frauen wie
Nadine was meinen sie möchte sich ändern
das offen darüber gesprochen wird
ist nicht dass man nicht als Mörder da
steht
denn erst wenn man ungewollt schwanger
ist in Deutschland verstehe man was das
wirklich bedeutet